erster in deutschland am donnerstag
schön dass sie mit teilweise ist damit
auch herzlich willkommen zu unserem
corona kompakt unter anderem mit vier
freudigen ladenbesitzern die bald wieder
öffnen dürfen taxifahrern die als
einkaufsdienst unterwegs sind und wir
sprechen mit dem wissenschaftler und
moderator harald lesch zunächst aber das
neueste vom heutigen tag und die frage
wie sicher sind die mund nasen masten
eigentlich obwohl es in deutschland noch
keine generelle pflicht gibt sie zu
tragen bestimmen sie immer öfter das
straßenbild masken
sie sollen helfen die ausbreitung des
corona virus zu verlangsamen
ob die qualität der maske stimmt wird
hier festgestellt bei der puls
gesellschaft dekra beginnen die masken
in einen klimaschrank bei 70 grad für 24
stunden
das machen wir um die lagerung
abzubilden um zu prüfen ob die masken
über einen längeren zeitraum auch
haltbar sind
entscheidend ist aber auch wie viele
viren eine solche maske abwehren kann
auch hier gibt es unterschiede wir haben
ein sehr breit gefächerte spektrum in
bezug auf diesen filter durchlass wir
haben das nun diesen wirklich sehr gut
liegen unterhalb von einem prozent
wir haben allerdings auch genau das
gegenteil dann sind die meisten sehr
schlecht in bezug auf die filterleistung
unterliegen die oberhalb von 80 prozent
schließlich ist noch eines wichtig der
richtige gebrauch der masken denn nur so
können sich diese zahlen weiter
verbessern
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand
heute 16 uhr 30 134 1753 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt 77 tausend
menschen gelten als genießen
es sind schwere zeiten aber auch zeiten
für kreativität und wenn man konzerte
schon nicht mehr besuchen kann
so kommt das konzert manchmal vor die
eigene haustür wie hier in hannover
konzerte gezielt für haushalte die sich
beworben haben
und der war ja keine großveranstaltung
ausmacht am ende freut es aber die ganze
nachbarschaft und bier ist auch im
angebot ging eine möglichst großzügige
spende
dabei achtet man natürlich auf die
einhaltung der korona bedingten
abstandsregel die einnahmen der konzerte
gehen übrigens an die momentan
arbeitslosen kollegen in der gastronomie
tolle idee auf jeden fall und ich freue
mich jetzt auf unseren heutigen experten
hier bei corinna kompakt und zwar ist
das professor harald lesch viel
bekannter als moderator von les kosmos
unter anderem hallo hallo kontaktsperre
haben wir schon hinter uns isolation die
berühmte ansteckung scobee wurde
abgeflacht und dann gestern weitere
entscheidungen der politik über das was
geht was noch nicht geht wo stehen wir
jetzt gerade in dieser krise also nach
aussage der experten ja immer auch er
gerade herr wieder vom
robert-koch-institut sagt dass er immer
wieder wir sind noch am anfang der
pandemie also wir müssen damit rechnen
dass das noch ziemlich lange dauert aber
wir sind aber auch schon dabei und haben
es hingekriegt diesen vervielfältigung
faktor also wie viel wie viele menschen
ein infizierter infiziert den haben wir
auf 1 gebracht das ist gerade so das was
man am besten ja was man erreichen kann
momentan es wäre natürlich besser es
werden weniger aber wir sind immerhin
schon da angekommen dass die maßnahmen
haben gegriffen
aber wir müssen leider noch damit
rechnen dass wir doch für für längere
zeit noch ganz gewaltige einschränkungen
hinnehmen müssen aber es wird der erste
lockerungen geben das heißt wir sind in
so einer phase die nach dem anfang
langsam sagen wir mal die mühen der
ebene beschreiben würde ich sagen die
mühen der ebene das merken wir das
trifft gut das muss man beißen wenn man
schon einiges geschafft hat vielen dank
erstmal herr professor lesch auch was
dran bleiben denn wir sprechen zwar
später noch einmal ausführlicher also
mir ist gleich als bundeskanzlerin
merkel gestern um kurz nach sechs das
podium der bundespressekonferenz in
berlin betreten hat hing wie auch
zehntausende einzelhändler gebannt an
den lippen wie viele viele andere dürfen
wir wieder öffnen ab wann und wie das
waren die großen fragen der verkäufer
auch die von philipp welt sind aus
münster
der betreiber eines mode ladens ist
seitdem mehr als erleichtert so viel
freude beim putzen seines ladens hatte
philip wenzel wohl noch nie endlich geht
es wieder los seit gestern nachmittag
ist klar
kleine läden bis 800 quadratmeter dürfen
ab montag wieder öffnen
in dem ersten moment also das gehört war
natürlich eine extreme euphorie
vorhanden
ja wir haben uns natürlich schnell auf
den weg gemacht um in unser ladenlokal
zu fahren und alles für für montag den
tod vorzubereiten den modeladen in
münster führt philipp mit seiner mutter
auch sie ist glücklich dass es wieder
losgeht allerdings nicht nur wegen des
geschäfts sondern vor allem auch wegen
des direkten kontakt zu ihren kunden
es war so kribbeln es war ein absolutes
kribbeln das was ich jetzt gespürt habe
und so dieser moment ja jetzt geht es
wieder los jetzt werden wir unsere
kundinnen wiedersehen
jetzt werden wir uns austauschen können
jeder hat in der zeit ja
unterschiedliche dinge erlebt wieder
miteinander reden zu können
doch auch wenn es sich fast anfühlt wie
vor corona die hygieneregeln erinnern
alle daran dass die krise noch dauern
wird
die hygiene auflagen werden wir
natürlich so erfüllen dass wir darauf
achten
viele kunden im geschäft haben dass wir
den abstand wahren das ist natürlich
unser desinfektionsmittel hier
aufstellen
im moment zählt allerdings dass es
überhaupt wieder losgeht und so geht es
vielen ja ich bin froh dass wir da bin
ich eröffnen können wir nicht eigentlich
ganz gut doch ich denke es könnte
vielleicht noch ein bisschen lockerer
sein ich glaube dass es noch ein
bisschen früh aber wir werden sehen
auch in diesen freiburger schuhgeschäft
bereitet man sich auf montag vor noch
aber herrscht unsicherheit wie die
hygiene vor allem gegenüber älteren
menschen eingehalten werden kann
wir haben noch keine klaren anweisungen
ja und da wartet man halt jetzt drauf
vorher kann man gar nichts klebeband
oder sonst irgendwas kann man noch
nichts machen sondern wir noch nichts
direktes wissen doch trotz aller
unwägbarkeiten die krise hat tatsächlich
auch schöne seiten
diese krise hat einen wahnsinns
zusammenhalt in der firma gegeben also
das muss man wirklich sagen und muss
echt danke sagen an alle kolleginnen die
da waren und so gehören die bilder der
leeren innenstädte dann hoffentlich auch
bald der vergangenheit an
die hoffentlich und eine andere
berufsgruppe die hofft dass auch ihre
lehren taxen bald der vergangenheit
angehören denn seit der kontaktsperre
ist meist eher stillstand angesagt aber
sie sehen schon einige hamburger
taxifahrer die haben was anderes gemacht
die haben umgesattelt und ein einkaufs-
und bringen dienst eingerichtet
einkaufsservice einen solchen auftrag
aus der zentrale bekommt er jetzt immer
öfter einkaufen fahren soll taxifahrer
andreas wettlaufer die idee eines
hamburger taxiunternehmens per anruf
oder klick im internet für alle die
nicht mehr selbst in den supermarkt
gehen möchten weil ihnen das
ansteckungsrisiko dort mit dem corona
virus zu hoch ist insbesondere ältere
menschen neben den service gerne in
anspruch
so auch renate piller sieht 78 und
gehört damit zur risikogruppe
das was sie nicht
christoph cappuccino und nennen das
heißt sowohl das zum kennen sie das
der sachen grün was ist ein finken boden
finden wir sind spezialität ist ein
bäcker auf finkenwerder der schönes brot
nach alten methoden backt und die
handlers da und das gibt es entscheiden
das ist aufgeschnitten und die verkäufer
wissen das auch okay alles klar
ich finde das toll was sie machen auch
wenn er nicht alles bekommen oder was
falsches bringen sollte natürlich sofort
nicht kriegt ihr ganz grobe schimpfe und
[Musik]
das muss er selber erst nein das ist
spielt alles keine rolle
ich werde wenn ich jetzt einkaufen geben
eine runde laufen die sachen ab gehe
natürlich wenn ich unsicher wenn sie
anrufen ich habe auch durch ihre nummer
und kann halt mit meinem handy
sie haben fragen mensch ist gar keine
baguettes und auch nicht so ein gebot
deutlich was anderes mitbringen
für renate piller gibt es zum taxi
service kaum alternativen es wichtig
meine freunde sind ja wie sie sich
vorstellen können
fast alle die gleiche altersgruppe und
deshalb also auch risikobehaftet und die
sind froh wenn sie ihre einkäufe alleine
machen können auch online bestellungen
im supermarkt dauern gerade ewig gerne
würde sie selber einkaufen system ist in
plausch auf der straße für einen schnack
hat aber auch andreas wettlaufer immer
zeit für ihn tragen die einkaufsfahrten
dazu bei einigermaßen über die runden zu
kommen elf jahre fährt er taxi aber so
einen heftigen einbruch des geschäfts
hatte noch nie erlebt es ist ein
bisschen zu dem was jetzt vielleicht der
staat dazu gibt und dann kommt man
vielleicht für ein zwei monate über
runde aber also im dritten monat
da nicht ganz schwarz als wenn der staat
nicht noch mal was gibt dann wird das
nicht reichen
die parkuhren am tag teilt er sich mit
den wenigen taxifahrern wie überhaupt
noch unterwegs sind trotz allem ist er
optimistisch dass er diese zeit
übersteht
angst habe ich wenn ich in drei monaten
den zustand immer noch haben dass die
wirtschaft das nicht durchhält
dass die leute auf dumme gedanken kommen
könnte ein sohn zu hause sitzen nicht
mehr wissen was sie machen sollen die
sozialen kontakte
das fehlt mir noch mehr single ich kenne
das aber jetzt darf ich nicht mal
kontaktmann portmann auch in seinem taxi
sitzt der momentan sehr um die
einkaufstouren sind eine ablenkung für
ihn und der dank der menschen denen er
hilft tut ihm gut
ich habe schon einkäufe gehabt wo die
dame dann auch wenn ich gefragt hat das
muss es diese woche getrennt
bringen sie irgendeine post mit die sind
auch sehr gelassen sind froh dass wir
kommen
das besondere schinkenbrot für frau kyla
hat er bekommen nicht für alle seiner
taxi kollegen kommen solche einkaufs
jobs sind frage natürlich leute und
kollegen ja noch so ist kein luft kann
man auch verstehen muss sie ja nicht
machen
ich mache es gerne für etwa 50 euro hat
andreas wettlaufer eingekauft 20 kommen
für staat und standzeit noch dazu ja das
ist ja vorher
das system muss finde ich auch gefunden
aber statt der motor hinein bild
mitgebracht hat das land in einer woche
will genannte tyler ihn wieder anrufen
und dann um sich die kosten zu teilen
vielleicht mit nachbarn einen sammle ein
kauf starten genau damit begrüße ich
jetzt auch noch mal den professor
buchautor und moderator lässt so damals
wir kommen zurück und gleich noch kurz
persönlich die frage an sie wie erleben
sie eigentlich die krise als mensch als
jemand der auch auf der zu hause bleibt
ja also ich bin ein bisschen ins kalte
wasser geworfen worden die universität
die hat er ist natürlich die lehre
völlig umgestellt das heißt von
präsenzveranstaltungen gibt es jetzt
alles digital
das muss man erst mal lernen diese
digitalen formen bin mal sehr gespannt
wie die studierenden das aufnehmen ich
erlebe es auf verschiedene weise
natürlich sagen wir eben auch gerade bei
den beiträgen gesehen
die einen sagen also das kriegen wir
schon irgendwie hin aber in wenn das
jetzt noch sehr viel länger dauert dann
gibt es probleme
insgesamt fand ich es oder finde ich es
einfach gut die die stimmung ist
eigentlich verhältnismäßig entspannt
locker noch auch wenn ich schon gehört
habe dass es so etwas gibt wie eine
corona fertig also eine disaster
müdigkeit weil man von den vielen
katastrophenmeldungen schon fast über
erschöpft ist weil der tag für tag
irgendwie zahlen kommen diagramme und
das ist schlecht und das ist schlecht
also das erlebe ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen dass ich das gefühl habe meine
güte es wäre schon schön wenn das
allmählich wieder zu ende
zu ende wäre man normalen zum normalen
leben übergehen könnte aber wir wissen
natürlich alle die sich ein bisschen
damit beschäftigen das wird noch sehr
lange dauern und das normale leben der
zukunft wird anders aussehen als das
normale leben der vergangenheit ganz
kurze nachfrage sie denn ich bin
gespannt wie sieht das aus naja wir
werden auf jeden fall uns deutlich mehr
glaube ich darum kümmern was das
stichwort daseinsvorsorge betrifft wir
machen ja jetzt die große erfahrung dass
unser gesundheitswesen wenn es sich neu
organisieren muss tatsächlich auch
extrem gut funktioniert großes lob
großen respekt an die arbeit derjenigen
die das in den krankenhäusern so
hingekriegt haben so schnell solche
umorganisationen vorzunehmen also aus
betten intensivbetten zu machen
beatmungsgeräte zu organisieren und
alles das ich glaube das wird in zukunft
die gesellschaft viel mehr beschäftigen
wie unser gesundheitssystem funktioniert
wir werden viel häufiger darüber reden
ob gewisse dinge nicht doch wieder in
europa produziert werden müssen damit
man einfach ein bisschen sicherer ist
bei gruppe an den ganz großen
handelswegen die wir über die welt haben
und wir werden vielleicht auch ein
bisschen er darüber nachdenken dass
diese just in time konzepte die wir ja
schon seit jahren wenn ich seit
jahrzehnten gewohnt sind sich vielleicht
ein bisschen auflockern müssen wir
werden viel mehr über vorräte nachdenken
das werden wir jetzt ja auch bei den
lockerungsmaßnahmen werden wir das hier
erleben dass eben dadurch dass dieses
diese diese wirtschaft so sehr auf den
durchfluss von waren angelegt ist haben
wir eigentlich kaum möglichkeiten
praktisch an einer stelle zu beginnen
mit dem gewissen vorrat und dann erst zu
warten dass die zum beispiel die
belieferung von von weiteren teilen
endlich kommen muss sondern heute muss
alles auf einmal anlaufen weil das ganze
so auf durchlauf angestellte ich glaube
das wird sich in der zukunft sehr
verändern sind es ja gewohnt als
wissenschaftler und als eloquenter
moderator dinge kompakt auf den punkt zu
bringen dafür bitte ich sie noch mal
kurz bei der nächsten frage und es geht
um joachim löw der am anfang dieser
krise gesagt in einer pressekonferenz
die welt erlebt einen kollektiven
burnout als würde sie sich gegen die
menschen auf lehnen wie stehen sie zu
dieser einschätzung
nein nein nein also was die menschheit
erlebnissen massiver stoppt also sowas
wie ein stau aber kein burnout sondern
sie erlebt dass eben natur tatsächlich
auf eine art und weise auf uns wirkt die
direkt unsere individuelle gesundheit
betrifft und in dem fall eben sogar das
gesamte gesundheitswesen
weil wir damit ja verhindern dass
risikogruppen ohne medizinische
behandlung bleiben sondern wir können
garantieren dass die leute tatsächlich
da auch entsprechend behandelt werden
ich glaube nicht dass es ein burn out
das ist ein ziemlich klares zeichen für
uns alle vorsichtiger mit natur
umzugehen weil die natur uns näher kommt
wir wissen ja das virus kommt letzten
endes aus einer gegend wo es eben über
die artgrenzen drüber gesprungen ist und
ich würde es eher als so eine art
warnschuss bezeichnen wir sollten in
zukunft daran denken dass so etwas immer
wieder passieren kann
es gibt ja noch andere herausforderungen
für die menschheit nämlich klimawandel
gerechtigkeitsfragen und so weiter und
vielleicht lernen wir anhand dieser
auseinandersetzung jetzt mit dem virus
auch uns als gemeinschaften wieder
messer besser zu sehen
ich fand es ich finde es wirklich
erstaunlich in vielen berichten die wir
momentan höheren merken wir ja der
soziale zusammenhalt ist verbessert
worden
die leute sind höflicher geworden auf
der straße also es ist es hat sich schon
vieles verändert ich denke es ist kein
burnout sondern es ist ein warnschuss
und wie das ist bei patienten die einen
warnschuss erlebt haben man kann es
danach besser machen und kann sich davon
erholen auch dass wir alle daraus lernen
dass wirklich auch beim alten was sie
gesagt haben vielen dank herr lesch für
ihre zeit und die antworten ihnen auch
bis bald weil wir ja und sowohl dieses
interview als auch alle bisherigen
expertengespräche bei corona kompakt
finden sie auch noch mal auf youtube und
zwar auf dem kanal der heute de morgen
sprechen wir mit einer biologin aus
münchen und wenn sie da eine frage
stellen möchten einfach eine
menschlichen land corona kompakt zdf de
und welche folgen das corona wir es für
die wirtschaft hat darum geht es heute
in einem zdf spezial um fünf vor halb
acht kroner krise die folgen für die
industrie heißt das